Eu tenho dois irmãos e uma irmã e a
ideia iniciar do meu pai e da minha mãe
era ter uma menina só e acabou encerrar
as atividades só que aí nasceu meu irmão
depois nasceu o meu outro irmão depois
nasceu eu e depois nasceu a minha irmã
ou seja né Tod todos nós crescemos a
nesse ambiente lindo e maravilhoso
sabendo que todos nós fomos indesejados
meu filho eu te amo tanto cara e nem era
para nascer Mas nasceu te amo irmão ou
você tem mais velho ou você tem mais
novo se você é um irmão mais velho você
vai ter um encosto na sua vida e para
onde você for você vai ter que levar o
diabo dessa criança eu acho que é por
isso que os pais pensam em ter mais de
um filho eles pensam assim vou ter um
filho aqui e vou mandar ele levar o
outro para todo lugar para me livrar
dessas pragas meu Deus e é qualquer
lugar Mãe vou jogar a bola levar seu
irmão Ô mãe esse menino tem que levar
para todo lugar que eu vou é sim mãe eu
vou pra festa levea seu irmão mãe eu vou
pro cabaré levea seu irmão também e não
deixa ele ver peito lá no cabaré não é
triste que a tua vida vira simplesmente
você cuidar do seu irmão para ele não
morrer é só isso é basicamente isso